i like making food item as a cake
because it's really easy to make to be
real
hi amine i'm an illusion cake artist
today we're going to make fast food
burger cake this is cherry cake batter
adding some oil i'm adding some milk
whisk until you don't see any cake
crumbs and i'm gonna add cherries the
eggs
mix it really good mix until you don't
see any eggs i'm gonna add a little bit
of red food coloring to it i picked red
and yellow because mcdonald has red and
yellow this reminds me of halloween it's
my favorite holiday i have lemon cake
batter already mixed and add egg a
little bit of oil you can use whisk or
spatula just want to make it really nice
i'm going to add lemon juice
then you can also add a little bit of
yellow food coloring
okay so i'm gonna pour
lemon cake batter
this cake batter looks like ketchup and
mustard
and i love it spread into a pan
cherry cake goes into pins
it's pretty really nice
and i usually go
i'm going to carve this cake looks like
burger buns first i'm gonna use cutter
and i'm gonna carve it all right this is
done
and this is gonna be my bottom the
bottom one is not as round as top one
because the bottom one is more flat cut
just a little bit on top and then flip
upside down and this is gonna be my
bottom bun time to make cake pops you
just need one scoop of buttercream and
then mix
really good with the cake crumbs so this
lemon cake is gonna be two patties for
the bird cake burger
and i'm gonna put this in the fridge so
that it gets a little sturdy
frosting time so i made this beautiful
cream cheese frosting and i like to use
this plastic scraps to make it smooth
okay and i put it in the fridge okay
here is my lemon cake pop i'm gonna
frost with chocolate ganache
and this is for the burger patty
okay it looks like a patty already we
have top bun and i'm gonna use modeling
chocolate to cover this bun corn starch
to sprinkle on the table so that
modeling chocolate doesn't stick on the
table use a rolling pin to make
chocolate a little
thinner and use a cutter to cut the
excess of modern chocolate i'm going to
cut it
top in a little more
then i like to press some lines
so that it doesn't look like perfectly
round because all buns doesn't look the
same okay here's my patty i would like
to cover with the modeling chocolate
with a little bit of brown food coloring
so that it matches fatty color sprinkle
cornstarch make sure it doesn't stick on
the table
[Music]
and i would like to use this piece of
foil to create the texture of a patty
sometimes i like to use everything i can
find in my kitchen or just my house and
this foil will make perfect texture of a
patty i'm gonna airbrush the top bun and
this is food coloring i mix with a brown
orange and yellow color
[Music]
i'm gonna paint patty with the edible
food paint
i use regular paint brush from regular
art store
i went to culinary school in the city i
was watching tv and cake boss was on it
seemed like oh i think i can do that but
i have no idea what they're using so i
started to search they have this one day
program that you make like a birthday
cake i went there i made a birthday cake
and it turned out really good it was
first time i ever baked cake
i'm gonna paint a little bit of glaze to
look more juicy looking patty i'm gonna
sprinkle some sugar patties done this is
a gelatin and it's going to be onion and
i'm chopping onions
no actually gelatin
i made a white chocolate ganache and add
a little bit of red and orange coloring
looks like big mac sauce and then all
mixed together with my gelatin onion i'm
using wafer paper to make lettuce so
first i'm gonna petal dust with a green
color randomly
spread it cut little pieces
spray water
put it on the mold this mold is for
flour petal just give a little bit of
texture and you can kind of just rip it
and it looks like lettuce
we're going to make american cheese i'm
using modeling chocolate break a little
bit of cornstarch before i mix it yellow
modern chocolate a little bit of red
[Music]
yay
okay let's make a pickle i'm using
modeling chocolate so i like to use this
serrated knife for the edge of pickle
just cutting it and then i use this tool
to make a little bit more pickly see
easy then i like to give a little bit of
texture pickle too let's paint it
i feel like there is no between either
you like pickle or you don't like pickle
okay it's done let's go time to build a
burger i'm putting cream cheese frosting
between bun and patty cheese thyme
this is big mac sauce
that's really chunky add some lettuce
i like to have a model when i paint
something real so i can get exact color
and texture
we want to put middle bun
we just need a tiny bit of cheese at the
end because we're just gonna see the
edge
some pickles i personally love pickles
so i'm gonna put extra pickles
more lettuce
[Music]
i'm using modelling chocolate to make
tiny sesame seeds
and i'm using torch to make sauce looks
more runny looking then i'm gonna use a
little bit of glaze on pickle because
pickle always
has
water okay it's done
[Music]
that's assembled big mac cake let's cut
it and see what happens
that's the completed fast food
hamburger cake
thank you for watching let us know what
you guys think
oh yes
[Music]
you